- [Voiceover] Hello, grammarians.
Today, we're talking
about verbs and bears.
We had previously established at least
one thing about the verb,
and that was that it can show actions.
But today I'd like to introduce the idea
that the verb can link
ideas to one another.
In fact, we have this whole class of verbs
that we call "linking verbs."
Or, if you want to call
it something fancier,
we call that "state of being verbs."
These linking verbs include all forms
of the verb "to be," which I have
handily written out for you.
So, I am, he is we are,
be nice, they were being,
they have been, he was, we were.
Now we use a linking verb when we want
to connect one idea to another.
So what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna divide the screen in half
between the action side and
the state of being side,
just to show you what I mean.
So we use action verbs to
show what something does,
whereas we use state of being verbs
to show what something is.
So let's bring it back to this bear.
Let's think of an action
for this bear to do.
What is a bear-like thing to do?
The bear eats a fish. That's an action.
That's something the bear is doing.
The bear is hungry,
however, is not something
that the bear is doing, it's
something that the bear is.
So what "is" is doing here, is connecting
the word "hungry," to the word "bear."
It's linking it.
Some verbs can be used both ways.
They can be used both as
actions, and as linking verbs.
I'll show you an example of that.
You could say, "The bear looked at me."
Which is to say the bear is doing a thing,
looking, at something, namely me.
But we could also say,
using the same verb,
"The bear looked lonely."
Now in this case, this is
describing how the bear looks.
What the bear looks like.
This looking is not
something the bear is doing,
it is how the bear appears to a viewer.
So, "looked" is connecting
"lonely" to "bear."
It is linking "lonely" to "bear."
It is a linking verb.
By the same token, we
could say, for an action,
"The bear smells a person."
What is it smelling?
A person.
But we could also say,
"The bear smells like cinnamon."
Which, I grant you, is pretty unlikely.
Don't go smelling bears.
But what "smells" is
doing here is connecting
the idea of cinnamon, to the bear.
The bear isn't smelling the cinnamon,
the bear smells like cinnamon.
And that's the difference between
a linking verb and an action verb.
A linking verb shows what something is,
an action verb shows what something does.
So the bear is hungry,
the bear looked lonely,
the bear smells like cinnamon.
These all reflect something
about what the bear is.
How it's being.
You can learn anything, David out.